do you finally want to understand
regression analysis then this is the
place for you my name is hannah and
welcome to this full course about
regression analysis after watching this
video you will know what regression
analysis is and what the differences
between simple and multiple linear
regression are further you will be able
to interpret your results understand the
assumptions for a linear regression and
also the use of dummy variables
and at the end i explain to you the
basics about logistic regression and of
course i'll also show you how to
calculate a regression easily online
let's get started
a regression analysis allows you to
infer or predict a variable
based on one or more other variables
let's say you want to find out what
influences the salary of people for
example you could take the highest level
of education the weekly working hours
and the age of people
now you can investigate whether these
three variables have an influence on the
salary
if you can do so you can predict a
person's salary by taking the highest
educational level the weekly working
hours and a person's age
the variable you want to infer the one
that you want to predict is also called
the dependent variable or criterion
the variables you use for your
prediction are called independent
variables or predictors
regression analysis can be used to
achieve two goals
first you can measure the influence of
one variable or several variables on
another variable
or you can predict a variable based on
other variables this is the second goal
in order to give you a feeling for this
let's go through some examples now
let's start by measuring the influence
of one or more variables on another
in the context of your research work you
might be interested in what has an
influence on children's ability to
concentrate
you're interested in whether you can
prove that there are parameters that
positively or negatively influence
children's ability to concentrate
but in this case you're not interested
in predicting children's ability to
concentrate
another example would be you could
investigate whether the educational
level of parents and the place of
residence have an influence on the
future educational level of children
this area is very research based and has
a lot of application in the social and
economic sciences the second area which
is using regressions for predictions is
more application oriented
let's say in order to get the most out
of hospital occupancy you might be
interested in how long a patient will
stay in the hospital so based on the
characteristics of the prospective
patient such as age reason for stay and
pre-existing conditions
you want to know how long this person is
likely to stay in the hospital
based on this prediction you can for
example optimize bad planning another
example would be that as an operator of
an online store you may be very
interested in which product a person is
most likely to buy so you want to
suggest this product to the visitor in
order to increase the sales of the
online store this is where regression
comes into play
what we now need to know is that there
are different types of regression
analysis and we get started with these
types right now
in regression analysis a distinction is
made between simple linear multiple
linear and logistic regression
in simple linear regression you use only
one independent variable to infer the
dependent variable
in the example where we want to predict
the salary of people we use only one
variable either for example if a person
has studied or not the weekly working
hours or the age of a person
in multiple linear regression we use
several independent variables to infer
our dependent variable
so we use the highest educational level
weekly working hours and the age of a
person
so therefore the difference between a
simple and a multiple regression is that
in one case we only use one independent
variable and in the other case we use
several independent variables both cases
have in common that the dependent
variable is matrix and major variables
are for example the salary of a person
the body size the shoe size or for
example their electricity consumption
in contrast to that logistic regression
is used when you have a categorical
dependent variable
so for example when you want to infer
whether a person is at high risk of
burnout or not
whenever yes and no answers are possible
you use logistic regression so in linear
regression the dependent variable is
matric in logistic regression it is
categorical
whenever the dependent variable is yes
or no you will use a logistic regression
does one person buy a product yes or no
is a person healthy or sick does a
person vote for a certain party yes or
no and so on and so forth in all these
cases it does not matter what scale
level the independent variables have
they can be either nominal ordinal
ometric
so as i just said the scale level of the
dependent variable can be metric ordinal
or nominal in all three cases so in the
simple linear in a multiple linear and
in a logistic regression the dependent
variable is metric in the linear case
and it is nominal or ordinal in the case
of a logistic regression
it is important to know that in the case
of a nominal or an ordinal independent
variable
the variables may classically have only
two characteristics such as gender with
male and female
if your variables have more than two
characteristics then you have to form
so-called dummy variables but we will
talk about dummy variables a bit later
so now a quick recap for you there is
the simple linear regression and the
question could be
does the weekly working time have an
impact on the hourly wage of people the
distinguishing point is that we have
only one independent variable in this
case
then there is the multiple linear
regression a question could be do the
weekly working hours and the age of
employees have an influence on the
hourly wage
in this case we have at least two
independent variables so for example
weekly working hours and age
and now let's look at the last case
which is logistic regression here the
question could be do the weekly working
hours and the age of employees have an
influence on the probability that they
are at risk of burnout
in this case burnout at risk has the
expressions yes or no
so now i hope you got a first impression
about what regression analysis is and
we'll move on to the linear regression
now
let's get started
as you already know a regression
analysis allows you to infer or predict
a variable based on one or more other
variables
but what is the difference between a
simple linear regression and a multiple
linear regression
let's first start with this simple
linear regression
the goal of a simple linear regression
is to predict the value of a dependent
variable based on an independent
variable the greater the linear
relationship between the independent
variable and the dependent variable is
the more accurate is the prediction
visually the relationship between the
variables can be represented in a
scatter plot the greater the linear
relationship between the dependent and
the independent variable
the more the data points lie on a
straight line
the task of a simple linear regression
is now to determine exactly the straight
line that best describes the
relationship between the dependent and
the independent variable in the context
of linear regression analysis a straight
line is plotted on the scatter plot
in order to determine the straight line
the linear regression uses the method of
least squares
let's say a hospital asks you to give
them an estimate based on the age of a
person how long this person will stay in
the hospital after a surgery the target
of the hospital operator is to optimize
the bad planning in this example your
dependent variable the one you want to
infer is the length of stay after
surgery your independent variable is the
age of a person the equation that
describes the model now looks like this
b is the slope and a is the receptor
point if a person would be zero years
old which doesn't really make sense in
this example the model would tell us
that this person stays eight days in the
hospital in order to calculate the
coefficients the hospital must of course
provide you with a sample of people
where you know the age and the length of
stay after surgery by using your data
you could find out that b is
0.14 and a is 1.2
this is now our model which helps us to
estimate the length of stay after
surgery based on the age of people now
let's say a person who is 33 years old
is registered for a surgery then we
would put 33 for x our model then tells
us that this person stays in the
hospital for
5.82 days after surgery now of course
the question is how do you calculate the
slope b and how do you calculate the
intercept a usually you use a statistics
program like data tab in the case of
simple linear regression however it is
also quite simple to do this by hand b
results from the correlation of the two
variables times the standard deviation
of the variable length of stay after
surgery divided by the standard
deviation of h
a is obtained by calculating the mean
value of the length of stay
minus the slope times the mean value of
the h
the regression line always tries to map
the given data with a straight line as
best as possible of course this always
results in an error this arrow is called
epsilon let's say we estimate the length
of stay after surgery of a person who is
33 years old our model tells us that the
person stays in the hospital for
5.82 days but in fact he or she stays in
the hospital for seven days then the
difference between the estimated value
and the true value is our error and
exactly the error epsilon now you have a
good overview of what a simple linear
regression is
and we proceed with the multiple linear
regression now
unlike simple linear regression multiple
linear regression allows for the
consideration of more than two
independent variables as we already know
the goal of a regression is to estimate
one variable based on several other
variables the variable to be estimated
is called the dependent variable or
criterion the variables that are used
for prediction are called independent
variables or predictors
multiple linear regression can be used
to control for the influence of a third
party variable
multiple linear regression is often used
in empirical social research as well as
in market research in both areas it is
of interest to find out what influence
different factors have on a certain
variable
therefore the creation for a simple
linear regression
looks like this we have one independent
variable x plus the constant if we now
go the way of multiple linear regression
we have several independent variables
the first variable the second variable
and the kth variable the coefficients
can now be interpreted similarly to the
linear regression equation if all
independent variables are zero we get
the value a if an independent variable
changes by one unit the corresponding
coefficient b indicates by how much the
dependent variable changes let's say x1
is the age of a person and b1 is 10.
then for every further year y is
increased by 10. if the person is 5
we have 5 times 10 which equals 50
so y is increased by 50. before we now
look at the interpretation of the
regression results i will first explain
to you how you can easily calculate a
linear regression online in order to do
this simply visit data tab you can find
the link in the video description and
just copy your own data into this table
then you simply click on the regression
tab
after you've copied your data into the
upper table your variables will appear
here below
now you only need to select your
dependent variable and one or more
independent variables of course this
data set is far too small but it just
serves us as an example your own data
set may of course have several thousand
rows let's say we want to find out what
influences a person's salary so we
choose salary as the dependent variable
as the independent variables we can now
choose gender age and for example weight
as soon as you've selected the variables
you want to use data tab calculates a
regression analysis for you since your
dependent variable has a matrix scale
level a linear regression is calculated
now you can see the results here
we will go through the interpretation of
the results in detail in a moment the
good thing is the data tab also helps
you with the interpretation
so just click here
a multiple linear regression analysis
was performed to examine whether male
age or weight variables significantly
predict salary the regression model
indicated that the predictors explained
48.99
of the variance
and the collective significant effect
was not found
f equals 2.56
p equals 0.1 and r squared is 0.49
but let's now go into more detail about
the interpretation of results your
results will be presented to you in this
form
you can now of course just use the
interpretation in words on data tab but
we'll go through each block individually
let's start with the model summary
the multiple correlation coefficient r
measures the correlation between the
dependent variable and the combination
of the independent variables what does
that mean here we see the equation for
linear regression our statistics program
like datadab calculates the regression
coefficients now you can sum up all the
values and with the summed values you
can calculate the correlation with the
dependent variable this correlation is
the multiple correlation coefficient r
or to say it in other words with the
regression coefficients and the
independent variables an estimate of the
dependent variable is calculated r now
indicates how strong the correlation is
between the true dependent variable and
the estimated variable
therefore the greater the correlation
the better the regression model the
coefficient of determination r squared
indicates how much the variance of the
dependent variable can be explained by
the independent variables your dependent
variable has a certain variance
the more of this variance we can explain
the better it is
let's take the example of how long you
stay in the hospital after surgery
of course not every person stays in the
hospital for the same amount of time
so we have a variation and it's this
variation that we want to explain with
the help of a regression model
if for example we can predict the length
of stay in hospital
very well with the age and the type of
surgery
this r squared is very large if we can
even explain everything the result would
be one in this case we could predict
exactly how long a person will stay in
the hospital after a surgery using only
the age and the type of operation and we
can explain all the variants of the
dependent variable but of course that
doesn't happen very often in practice
r squared overestimates the coefficients
of determination when too many
independent variables are used to fix
this issue the adjusted r square is
often calculated
the standard estimation area indicates
by how much the model
overestimates the dependent variable on
average
let's say you want to predict the length
of stay in days after surgery
if your standard estimation area for
example is 4
this would mean that you miscalculate on
average by 4 days with your prediction
now of course your question to the
hospital management would be whether an
average deviation of four days is too
much
or whether the hospital says great this
enables us a much better planning
security
so next this table is displayed
here the so-called f-test is calculated
the f-test tests the null hypothesis
whether the variance explanation
squared in the population is zero this
test is often not of great interest the
test is equivalent to asserting that all
true slope coefficients in the
population are zero
so b1 is zero b2 is zero and up to bk is
zero in this case since we have a very
small data set in our example the
results show that the null hypothesis
cannot be rejected
the p-value is greater than 0.05
and we assume based on available data
that all coefficients are zero
so now we reach the probably most
interesting table
here we see the unstandardized
coefficients the standardized
coefficients and the significance level
capital b the unstandardized
coefficients are just the coefficients
that you can put into your regression
equation
so if we want to predict the salary we
have a constant of 1920
plus the value of the gender variable
plus the value for the age variable plus
weight this allows us to use the
unstandardized regression coefficients
to build our regression model if we want
to predict the salary we now only have
to insert the variables
better are the standardized coefficients
here you can see which variable has the
greatest influence on the salary in this
case age has the greatest influence on
salary because better of age has the
greatest amount and finally we see the
significance value for the coefficients
values smaller than 0.05
are considered significant
in this case we see that not a single
coefficient is significant
what does that mean now the null
hypothesis in each case is that these
coefficients are 0 in the population
if the p-value is greater than
0.05
we cannot reject this null hypothesis
based on the available data and thus it
is assumed that the coefficients in the
population are not different from zero
and therefore the variables have no
influence on salary due to the fact that
i've used a data set that is actually
very small
it's difficult to reach significant
values
of course when calculating a regression
analysis you also have to check the
assumptions if the assumptions are not
fulfilled you cannot interpret the
results of the regression meaningfully
therefore we now take a look at the
assumptions the assumptions for the
linear regression are as follows
there must be a linear relationship
between the dependent and the
independent variables the error epsilon
must be normally distributed
third assumption is that there must be
no
multi-collinearity or no instability of
the regression coefficients and finally
there must not be heteroskedasticity
the variance of the residuals must be
constant over the predicted values and
now we'll go into each point in more
detail let's get started
in a linear regression a straight line
is thrown through the data
this straight line should represent all
points as good as possible if the points
are non-linear the straight line cannot
fulfill this task let's look at these
two graphs in the first one we see a
nice linear relationship between the
dependent and independent variable here
the regression line can be drawn in a
meaningful way in the second case
however we see that there is a clearly
non-linear relationship between the
dependent and the independent variable
therefore it's not possible to put the
regression line meaningfully through the
points since this is not possible the
coefficients of the regression model
cannot be interpreted meaningfully or
errors in the prediction can occur
that are larger than expected therefore
we have to check at the beginning
whether there is a linear relationship
between the dependent and the
independent variables this is usually
done graphically
the next requirement is that the error
epsilon must be normally distributed in
order to check this there are two ways
one is the analytical way and the other
one is the graphical way when using the
analytical way you can use either the
kolmogorov smyrnoff test or the shapiro
wilk test if the p-value is greater than
0.05
there is no deviation of the data from
the normal distribution
so it can be assumed that your data are
normally distributed however these
analytical tests are not used that often
anymore because they tend to always
attest normal distribution in small
samples and they become significant very
quickly in larger samples thus rejecting
the null hypothesis that the data is
normally distributed therefore the
graphical version is used more and more
for the graphical solution you can
either look at a histogram or better the
qq plot the more your data lies on the
line the better is the normal
distribution and now we come to the
hedgerow's capacity
another assumption for the linear
regression is that the residuals have a
constant variance
since your regression model never
exactly predicts your dependent variable
in practice you always have a certain
error
now you can plot your dependent variable
on the x-axis and the arrow on the
y-axis the arrow should scatter evenly
over the whole range
then
homoscedasticity is present however if
the results look like this
then we have
heteroscedasticity in this case we have
different error variances depending on
the value range of the dependent
variable this should not be the case so
and before i show you how you can check
the assumptions online we now come to
the last assumption which is no
multicollinearity
multicollinearity means that two or more
independent variables are strongly
correlated with each other the problem
with multicollinearity is that the
effect of individual variables cannot be
clearly separated let's look at the
regression equation again
there we have the dependent variable and
here the independent variables with the
respective coefficients
so now for example if there is a high
correlation between x1 and x2 or if
these two variables are almost equal
then it is difficult to determine b1 and
b2 if both are completely equal the
regression model does not know what b1
and b2 should be
this means that the regression model
becomes unstable if you want to use the
regression model for a prediction it
does not matter whether there is
multicollinearity or not in a prediction
you're only interested in how good the
prediction is but you're not interested
in how big the influence of the
respective variables is however if the
regression model is used to measure the
influence of the independent variable on
the dependent variable
there must not be multicollinearity and
if there is the coefficients can not be
interpreted meaningfully
so now the question is how can we
diagnose multicollinearity
if we look at the regression equation
again we have the variables x1 x2 up to
the variable xk
we now want to know if x1 is quite
identical to another variable or a
combination of the other variables in
order to do this we simply set up a new
regression model in this new regression
model we take x1 as the new dependent
variable if we can now predict x1 very
well by using the other independent
variables we don't need x1 anymore
because we can use the other variables
instead if we would now use all
variables it could be that the
regression model is unstable in
mathematics we say that the equation is
over determined we can now do this for
all other variables so we estimate now
x2 by using the other independent
variables and we estimate x k by using
the other independent variables
for all k regressions in this case we
have k new regression models
we calculate the so called tolerance or
the v i f value the tolerance is
obtained by taking 1 minus r squared
which is the variance explanation
once again the variance explanation
indicates how much of the variance of x1
can be explained by the other variables
the more it is the more one speaks of
multicollinearity
if these variables can explain a hundred
percent of the variance of x1
then we no longer need x1 in the upper
equation
if the tolerance is less than 0.1
you have to be careful because in this
case we could have multiple linearity on
the other hand we have the vif value
the vif value is calculated by dividing
1 by the tolerance
accordingly you have to be careful if
the values are greater than 10
and now i will show you how you can test
the assumptions online if you want to
test the assumptions online with data
tab
you only need to select your variables
and then click on check assumptions
now you see a nice overview of the
results here
you can check the linearity the normal
distribution of the error
the multicollinearity
and the heteroscedasticity
it's very simple just try it yourself
now it's time to look at dummy variables
you have to use dummy variables if you
want to use categorical variables with
more than two values as your independent
variables
as independent variables or predictors
either metric or categorical variables
with two expressions can be used
of course it's also possible to use
variables with more than two categories
and i will explain this to you in the
next slides
categorical variables with two
characteristics are also called
dichotomous
an example would be gender with the
cadagras male and female
let's say you coded female as zero and
male as 1.
in this case
female would be the reference category
if we now look at the regression
equation and say the variable x1 is
gender
then b1 is the regression coefficient
for gender now how can we interpret b1
we said zero is female and one is male
so we just put that in
then we have zero times b1 for a female
person
and 1 times b1 for a male person
accordingly b1 indicates the difference
between male and female
let's say we want to predict the income
of a person so why
is the income
if a person is male this person earns
more by the amount of b1 than a woman if
the person is male there's a one here
and we have one times this value
if the person is female there is a 0
here and we have 0 times this value
if b1 is 400 for example then it means
that man earn 400 euros more than women
according to this model
now we've discussed how to handle
variables with two values
further we should look at what we do
when we have a variable with more than
two values or categories
let's say you want to predict the fuel
consumption of a car
based on its horse power and the vehicle
type and let's say there are only three
vehicle types sedan sports car and
family van
thus here we have a variable vehicle
type with more than two characteristics
but for a regression model we need a
categorical variable with two
characteristics
therefore the question is now what
should we do next
in order to use categorical variables in
a regression
we have to create dummy variables
this means that we simply create three
new variables
each new variable has two
characteristics
these characteristics are zero and one
or yes or no so here we have our vehicle
type with the characteristics sedan
sports car and family van
now we create one new variable for each
characteristic
so first we create a variable is it a
sea then yes or no second would be is it
a sports car yes or no and our third
variable asks is it a family van yes or
no so before we had one variable and now
we got three variables which are
dichotomous
and therefore they all have only two
characteristics
and these three new variables can now be
used in the regression model
so the next question is now what does
that mean for the data preparation you
originally have one column with the
vehicle type where the individual
vehicles from your sample are listed
the first is aceton the second is also a
sedan the third is a sports car and so
on and so forth
out of this table you create your three
new variables
what is the first car a c then so you
put a one here
and a zero for the others
it's not a sports car and it's not a
family van the second one is also sedan
so we'll put a one here again
and the third one is a sports car so
we'll put a 1 here and the others are 0.
by continuing this procedure we have
finally created our new dummy variables
now there's only one important thing to
note the number of dummy variables is
always the number of characteristics
minus one
why is that the case
if we know that it is a sedan we are
sure that it's not a family van
if we know that it is a sports car we
can also be sure that it's not a family
van
and if it's not a season and not a
sports car
we can be sure that it is a family van
accordingly one of the three variables
is not needed because this information
is redundant
therefore n minus 1 dummy variables are
created
so in this case we only need the dummy
variable is it a sedan or is it a sports
car
of course you can also drop sedan and
use the other two
and now i show you how you can create
the dummy variables online with data tab
in this example we use salary as our
dependent variable
and as independent variable the age and
the company the variable company here
has three characteristics bmw ford and
gm
now we can see that datadep
automatically creates the dummy
variables
once we have the age and once the new
dummy variables is it bmw and is it ford
since we only need n-1 dummy variables
the last category was dropped
if your dependent variable is
categorical then you need the logistic
regression and logistic regression is
what we are going to look at now
in the previous part we discussed linear
regression in a linear regression the
dependent variable is metric for example
it could be salary or hate
now let's look at the logistic
regression here the dependent variable
is a categorical variable
let's say you want to predict whether a
person is at risk for burnout or not you
want to make this prediction by asking a
person's highest educational attainment
weekly working hours and a person's age
since the variable whether a person is
at risk for burnout or not is a
categorical variable
you have to use a logistic regression
the logistic regression is a special
case of regression analysis and it is
calculated when the dependent variable
is normally or ordinally scaled
let's look at a few examples first for
an online retailer you need to predict
which product a particular customer is
most likely to buy
in order to do this you receive a data
set with past visitors and their
purchases from the online retailer in
this case you need a logistic regression
because your dependent variable is a
categorical variable namely which
product is a particular customer most
likely to buy the second example comes
from the medical area you want to
investigate whether a person is
susceptible to a certain disease or not
for this purpose you receive a data set
with diseased and non-deceased people
as well as other medical parameters
again in this case you need a logistic
regression because a dependent variable
is categorical and it asks is a person
susceptible to a particular disease or
not and the last example comes from
politics the question could be would a
person vote for party a
if there were elections next weekend so
again a categorical dependent variable
with yes and no as response options what
is logistic regression now
in the basic form of logistic regression
diagonal variables that is variables
with the characteristics 0 and 1 or yes
or no can be predicted for this purpose
the probability of occurrence of
characteristic 1 which is characteristic
present is estimated in medicine for
example a common goal is to find out
which variables have an impact on a
disease in this case zero could be not
deceased and one deceased and the
influence of age gender and for example
smoking status on this particular
disease
could be examined let's look at this in
a graphical way so we have our
independent variables age
gender and smoking status and we use
these three variables
in order to predict whether a person is
likely to get a certain disease or not
so the dependent variable is will the
person get a disease or not
so maybe now you might ask yourself the
question
and why do i need a logistic regression
for this
why can't i just use a linear regression
a quick recap in a linear regression
this is our regression equation
now we have a dependent variable that is
zero or one therefore
no matter what value we have in a
dependent variables
we always get either zero or one
if we are using a linear regression we
would simply put a linear straight line
into these points
the graph shows that values between plus
and minus infinity can now occur the
goal of logistic regression is to
estimate the probability of occurrence
not the value of the variable itself
so we want to know how likely it is that
a value of 1 will be the result of the
given values for our independent
variables
the range of values for the prediction
is thus restricted to the range of 0 to
1. in order to ensure that only values
between 0 and 1 are possible the
logistic function is used the logistic
model is based on the logistic function
the important thing about the logistic
function is that only values between 0
and 1 are possible
so no matter where we are here on the x
axis between minus and plus infinity we
can only get values between 0 and 1 as a
result and that is exactly what we want
the equation for logistic regression now
looks like this we have 1 divided by 1
plus e
to the power of minus set for set we now
use the usual equation from the linear
regression which is the equation here
below b1 to bk are the regression
coefficients and a
is the on points x1 to xk are the
independent variables after we insert
all that our logistic function looks
like this now we need to determine the
coefficients
so that our model best represents the
given data in order to solve this
problem we use the so-called maximum
likelihood method there are good
numerical solutions that help us solve
the problem so usually we just use a
statistics program and it will give us
the values b1 b2 up to bk
finally i will now show you how to
calculate a logistic regression online
with data tab
in order to do this you just visit
datadeb.net
and you copy your own data into this
table
when you select a categorical dependent
variable a logistic regression is
automatically calculated let's say your
dependent variable is a person buys a
product or not with the expressions yes
and no
and the independent variables are salary
and age after you click on the variables
a logistic regression is automatically
calculated and now you get the results
which you can see below the first table
is the so called classification table
this table tells us how well we can
classify the categories with the
regression model after that we get the
model summary and the coefficients
i hope you like this video and see you
next time